- I, for the billionth time
on this show,
am a counter-puncher.
I react to the opportunities in
front of me at that moment.
I'm not predicting here.
I'm telling you the past.
The past will tell you the future.
It's always the same game.
I would tell you if I'm
a photographer right now
the number one place
I would build an audience on,
number one, is Snapchat.
I predict in 2016 that
Snapchat will have a
number one, two or three
spot in the most important
apps in the world.
(ding)
Twitter has a firehose problem.
Twitter has gotten noisy.
Twitter is noisy as hell.
Twitter's struggling.
People don't understand it.
It's losing attention.
(ding)
Nintendo.
- [Stephanie] Why?
- Because they're fucking up.
Like there's no 15 year old,
the fact that Nintendo
is not winning
in app gaming is ludicrous.
(buzzer)
I am predicting that Facebook
acquires Instagram.
(ding)
- Music.ly is the
emerging social network
with junior high kids
in America and China.
It has a chance.
(ding)
(light music)